هي بالفعل من الجيل للخمس لكن لها خصائص
اخرى كثيره ليلى نتعرف عليها في هذه
الخلاصه وطبعا لان هنالك اسئله كثيره سلطت
الضوء على هذا النوع من الطائرات وخصائصها
هذه الطائرات 22
تعرف بانها مكون الاساسي في سلاح الجو
الامريكي ودخلت الخدمه عام
2005 كاول مقاتله شبح من الجيل الخامس
توصف بانها مقاتله التفوق الجوي لجمعها
بين تقنيات التخفي واجهزه استشعار عاليه
الدقه وبهيكل طائره شديد المناوره ورؤيه
للطيار بزاويه
360 درجه دون ان يكون قابلا للكشف
تتميز ايضا بقدره على التحليق بسرعات
فائقه تقدر بضعف سرعه الصوت وتصل هذه
السرعه القصوى الى اكثر من
2500 كيلو متر في الساعه تستطيع التحليق
ايضا على ارتفاع يقدر بنحو خمسه عشر
كيلومترا
وبمدن يصل الى اكثر من 3000
يتمتع ايضا تتمتع محركاتها بفوهات دفع
المصممه لتستطيع التحرك بشكل عمودي وفي اي
اتجاه وفيها ثلاثه مخازن للاسلحه من
الصواريخ الى القنابل والمدافع الرشاشه
هذه القدرات الكبيره للطائره التي تضمن
تفوق الولايات المتحده وهي مرتها الجويه
على مستوى العالم دفعت الكونجرس في سبتمبر
2016 الى اصدار قانون يحضر على الشركه
المصنعه تصديرها الى الخارج ورفضت طلب
رفضت طلباتهم بالفعل من دول كاستراليا
والياب واسرائيل لشراء هذه الطائره